اعداد القهوه في صنعاء قد يؤدي الى الموت
او الاصابه بتشوه في حاله اسطوانه الغاز
سيئه قد تسبب انفجارها في اي وقت
حدث هذا مع ذكرى وجدها انتظر الجدو فنجان
قهوه صباحيه من حفيده وبمجرد ان اشعلت
الغاز وقع على الانفجار انهار سقف المنزل
فقد الجد في الحادث واصيبت الحفيده
[موسيقى]
طبعا حرقتنا
وقديما فوقها الدوره الثانيه
انا صاروا بها المستشفى وفي مضاعفات لحد
الان رجلي
وجهي كمان شويه
الغاز التي يستخدمها الناس في اليمن لا
تتوفر فيها مواصفات السلامه حيث يؤدي
تلفها وتسرب الغاز منها الى وقوع حوادث
متكرره
لا يساوي 10% من ما كنا نعمل له قبل 2016
نحن بنشاركه اليمنيه الغاطسه صناعه خلال
الفتره السابقه
تلقينا العديد من الشكاوي من الاخوه
المواطنين حول انعدام ماده الرائحه ماده
المركب تن يعلم الجميع ان ال ال الجهه
المسؤوله عنها هي شركه صافر
للاستكشاف والانتاج من جهته الشركه
المتخصصه في انتاج الغاز وتعبئته في
اسطوانات بان عملها مطابق للمواصفات
والمعايير العالميه
جمعيه المدنيه اقترحت فرض مبلغ سنويا على
ناقلات الغاز باستخدامه في سياده اسطوانات
الغاز المنزليه الثالثه
مليار ونصف وعلى اساس انهم 400 الى 500
سنه
المقترحوا لم يجد طريقه حتى الان مثل كثير
من المقترحات الاخرى في شتى القطاعات
الحصول على اسطوانه غازي في مناطق باليمن
امر صعب حقا فهي غير متوفره بما يكفي
وتوزيع المتوفر منها متذبذب وما يحصل عليه
الناس قد يكون اسطوانه غازا تفضي الى
الموت بدلا من طهي الطعام محمد العطاب
الجزيره من مصنعيه صيانه اسطوانات الغاز
صنعاء